[Musique]
directement avec le ski et kelly
convenir il ça va être la folie ce soir
salut moi jean luc alors il nous reste
quelques images des quatre tirs oui
c'est un reliquat de l'électronique de
mercredi est d'ailleurs avant de passer
aux ruines qu'est ce que je propose
c'est de robert quand même pour le
plaisir
un petit vent le vent la semaine celui
qui avait mis à jean michel bergue
regardez bien
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
alors on est dans l'ambiance maintenant
on peut écouter une question donc je
dors je m'appelle stéphane depuis la
rentrée on peut vous demander ce qu'on
veut et vous nous régaler donc je
voulais savoir est ce que vous vous
livrez aussi les sushis et si oui est ce
que vous pourriez passer vers 21h30 avec
expéditif plaisir non non je comprends
cette question mais non on en sert il ne
livre pas encore à domicile pas tout
faire il a déjà assez de boulot à
négocier des droits sportifs
gagnez des cadeaux le plus simple c'est
d'être sur le plateau
c'est à dire ce qui est arrivé à jean
michel la semaine dernière puisqu'on lui
a offert une boîte de préservatifs les
hauts récents ce qui semblait une bonne
idée
une bonne nouvelle aux yeux de thierry
mais jean michel lui expliquer pourquoi
le côté fléau du préservatif était
superflu pour lui trop dangereux
[Musique]
le groupe dans l'annuaire des noms
mais qui
c'est toujours
parlant jamais savoir
et
[Musique]
jean victoire
josé riga
m
les égarés
non
oui
et match que je pense que vous pouvez le
traité d' homme le plus lourd du monde
n'ont jamais son nom
ah ouais vraiment ces moments qu'il
fallait petit moreau intéresser mon
petit mot pour lui dire que c'est plus
lourd du monde à morrow effectivement il
ne revient pas à mon chéri raison mon
bas tu ta réseau aller d'autres choix et
pour jean-michel son sexe est une des
sept merveilles du monde
et après vous laquelle les sept
merveilles réfléchissez c'est simple un
monument de lumière la réponse du
modeste
d
avec
mais en fait moi ce dont je me rends
compte c'est que mode thierry mots mais
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi lourds
la prenez conscience au bout de six ou
huit ans qu'on milite alors finalement
les deux l'idée d'être des préservatifs
fluorescence et que c'était beaucoup
jean michel le problème c'est que tout
va s'écrouler en un instant je fait un
bond de 5 secondes dans le temps c'est
la suite de la conversation il n'y a pas
de trucage tout est normal sauf que
regarder bien entre les mains de jean
michel
je vous rappelle il tenait une boîte de
capotes
[Musique]
à
après qu'un tour
ça va
[Applaudissements]
c
aller loin et bien sûr les chéris mais
ce qui n'aura protéger mais très bien
ces captages vous protégez vous bien sûr
inchangés mercredi
allez allez non ce sont là le phare
d'alexandrie n'éclairera pas les bateaux
chez nous c'est pourquoi est ce que jean
michel jarre michel et le mec le plus
facile à voler du monde même si vous
êtes un très mauvais pickpockets tenter
votre chance ça peut passer
c'est dans ce système un homme regarder
entre lui et thierry vous allez voir on
a vraiment de flèches
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
il est le fils de thierry moreau devant
la star allait la réaction flippant de
la semaine maintenant on la doit à
gilles verdez c'est cyril avait demandé
à enora d'imiter une hôtesse de l'air
russe
oui il aurait pas dû bonsoir monsieur
karl heinz a il y allait de boga juste
et les deux un lien sur les côtés et si
tu veux tu peux me suivre bébé
ça n'est pas possible
parce que c'est clair il a bandé c'est
bon de passer à tout ce que valaient pas
voulu voir semaine et on commence par la
même séquence de l'hôtesse de l'air
russe
car si gill a été subjuguée tout le
monde n'a pas eu la même réaction
[Musique]
bonsoir des vous se veut kyle hines
j'en connais qui sont dans l'avion mais
qui ont déjà décollé
moi j'arrête l'absence des deux mais
surtout mimie mathy en fait parce que je
pense qu'en télévision
ouais ce match à 100 la voyait pas sur
six catégories tu dors et fais mon
secret je vois là je suis chaud que j'ai
peur des cassures sage en tête parce
qu'on savait que moi j'ai dit souvent
d'un fait nul puisque tu fais mieux
qu'une poule
sa belle mort
la mort
clermont
contré
les métiers pour passer
[Applaudissements]
l'arrêt de la danse
les passions
je vous donne ma boule
[Musique]
alors oui c'est le cuir merci jean luc
le bras de liste
[Applaudissements]